[Music]
we're going into a new year i always try
to track finances and all that good
stuff and so i spent a bunch of time
going through all the latest and
greatest ios apps and desktop apps and
just seeing what is out there what's new
and so i'll just give you real quick
there's one tim you would love this one
actually i'm not joking it's called
kubera
k-u-b-e-r-a dot-com
it is it's more like spreadsheet style
but it ties in all of your banks and it
also ties in all of your cryptocurrency
as well oh that's interesting it's like
a net worth tracker and it's just it's
very simple but very powerful it is it's
beautiful
it's awesome and that's a cool uh
screenshot on the on the main one on the
website
yeah
yeah it's it's like super super simple
it's just more of like where how am i
doing net worth wise across a bunch of
different assets that's cool on the
day-to-day budgeting side killer ios app
that i just fell in love with is called
copilot so you can go to copilot.money
sadly there's no android or desktop app
yet but they say that's coming
and then lastly
mint
old school mint i hated mint for years
and years and years
the reason i hate it is because it's
packed with ads all over the place my
buddy was like hey you need to check out
mint again they need an nft seriously ad
free but it's gotten so much better so
if you if you gave up on mint a while
ago it's time to go back and take
another look because they completely
redesigned it and it's it's a lot better
but but copilot.money is my favorite on
ios and kubera for overarching kind of
net worth tracking is is the go-to's
amazing i've tried probably two dozen of
them over the last month or so
let me ask a silly question i i know
you're not
scraping by
uh you're doing pretty well what what do
you find
you are
more
fluent with budgeting
apps i don't budget than anyone i know
well what do you consider this then
well is it just so you can swim in your
pool of money like scrooge mcduck and do
the backstroke what is it that you like
about the tracking
well i would say that for most people
it's going to be about the general
budgeting
for me
i don't want to say this sounds really
like bougie or whatever but like i have
someone that does budgeting to make sure
we're on track and stuff like yeah not
that we need like i just want to know if
i'm spending too much money on wine or
on travel or on like you know at the end
of the year it's always nice to sit down
and be like okay here's what we did
here's how our stocks did here's how our
crypto did you know i just kind of like
having that holistic view and then also
like you know how much are we spending
on
the kind of more stuff that we could
dial back on a little bit like on the on
the crazy wines or the like you know
travel or whatever it may be so it's
it's that's what it is for me so it
tracks now if we look at say
kubera kubera that's not going to be
your budgeting that's assets yeah that's
assets it's just like overarching like
all of your different banks brokerage
stocks currencies
it's like almost like a spreadsheet but
better it just pulls in all the data it
has all the right connections got it
that is the go to dashboard just to see
how am i doing across the board if
you're one of these people that has a
401k here and some robinhood crypto over
here
and fidelity here and wealth front there
like it'll bring it all together under
one roof so you can see everything
cool
did i get it is really cool it's the
best
just i want to see how i'm doing you
know
it's cool
you know what i've also
heard great things about
uh also from
listeners and full disclosure they do
sponsor the podcast but i did a lot of
vetting and
and reached out to you know ramit seti
and reached out to mr money mustache if
you know who that is and a number of
folks i just have ramit at my house two
days ago by the way oh no kidding yeah
he was in town he's so fun he's a great
guy uh and you need a budget y-n-a-b oh
ynab yeah ynab yeah ynab is fantastic
yeah i i should have included that it's
old school it's been out for a long time
but ynab for people that are you know if
you're really into budgeting i'd say
ynab is like for the hardcore hardcore
co-pilot i would i would say does
it it's not they don't have the desktop
app so you can't really get as deep but
it but it's it's co-pilot is more i
think it's a better interface yeah you
know i don't always judge products this
way but i look at the level of cult
following like how intense is the cult
following and why not like people put it
on their license plates
you know they buy a car for cash for the
first time or pay off a house or
it's
pretty
awesome to see just how loyal and
dedicated a lot of these folks are i
will also check out kubera that's uh
that's that's super interesting i do
most of the stuff on
on desktop so i could use something that
would actually tie
lots together simply
so i'll take a look at that one as well
and i use things like copilot and mint
you know you say budgeting you're right
i don't really pay a ton of attention
that but
if they do things like big purchase
detection and they'll send you a push
notification so if you do have fraud or
something weird going on yeah you get a
push and you're like oh wait a second
did i actually buy that you know it's
always nice to have little things like
that
you